foreign
let's go to John in Flint Michigan
what's up brother John how we doing
I'm okay how are you doing John good man
good morning to you good morning to you
so what's going on hey by the way has it
started snowing like crazy there in in
Flint
no we have no snow here no snow here wow
that's not what I expected wow man well
so what's up man how can I help
so um my question is just dealing with
like everyday stressors right now um I
have a wife that is uh has a
neurological disorder and um I I've
already had some bills and I'm just
really extremely stressed out and
kind of losing my mind and really what
to do because I mean I'm in a situation
where I'm the useful worker I can't
really reach out to anyone because I
don't have anyone to reach out to and
it's just one of those situations where
I just don't know how to deal with this
dress anymore hmm tell me about your
wife man
so
um my wife has a very difficult past
path of
um the emotional and physical abuse most
of her life
um and she'll she has multiple different
uh mental disorders but uh last year she
was diagnosed with
um a neurological disorder that causes
her to essentially lose control of her
entire body where it paralysis area she
won't be able to speak she won't be able
to talk what's it called all right speak
talk walk do anything
um and so that's been an upwards battle
since earlier this year
um when it got diagnosed what was the
diagnosis what's the official diagnosis
um it's called
um
vestibular migraines is what it's called
um it's a misleading name because it
actually doesn't deal with migraines it
deals with
um
blockages within the brain which doesn't
send the signals to where they need to
go is it like inflammatory of of the
brain yeah that's yeah exactly okay
um
man so do you got little ones
yes we do we have two little ones oh man
three and seven three and seven man
number one I'm sorry dude that sucks
that's hard
it's hard man it's been a long I it was
it was hard before this diagnosis wasn't
it
um how'd you meet her
um me and my wife actually met
um at a bar on Veterans Day when me and
a couple of my buddies were out
celebrating veteran days
man are you veteran yes I am where'd you
serve
I wasn't a Marine Corps for six years
six years man
uh Stateside or deployed
stay safe very cool man well thank you
for your service my brother appreciate
you
um tell me about your experience in the
Marines
um I mean I loved it I mean I was
actually planning on going back once I
got done with law school and passed the
bar but that just never happened because
life changes but um are you in law
school what's that are you in law school
now no I've already graduated law school
but I haven't passed my state bar ah
okay
um so did you failed the first time out
yep okay
not that you had anything going on or
anything like that all right right wow
man
you like the Marine Corps huh
yeah no I mean it's it's a it's a life
it's lifestyle I mean it's it's
something that will forever change you
so you want to go back and do Jag with
them yeah that's what the original plan
was but I mean now I mean
I'm right now I work in the mortgage
business I underrate loans okay and
stuff like that so I mean as much as I
I'm not as young as that you once was so
I I just there's no point in going back
anymore
so you're done done though
yeah
it's more the uh fantasy it's cool to
work out and watch choco videos it's
pretty cool right
actually yeah
um
man
tell me about your financial situation
so
um back in September I was actually like
all of my previous job because they
weren't willing to work with me to deal
with taking my wife to and from doctor's
appointments and uh taking my kids to
and from school
so that was actually a back and forth
deal with domination and terminating me
the day that I actually told them hey
federal states this and you need to give
me accommodations well three hours after
I sent that email they terminated me
um so I was out of a job for over a
month okay
um so everything I had saved up I used
towards the bills to push them out as
hard as I could
and even still that put me probably
about three grand in the hole okay and
so and then this job you have now are
you making decent money to pay bills and
get caught back up all the time
so I it covers the bills but it really
doesn't leave much room for savings okay
until I get out of training and start
actually producing
money or pretty soon loans again there
you go
so this is a new job
yeah okay why Flint Michigan why y'all
living in Michigan
um well we we both grew up here we I
mean we don't live necessarily in Flint
we live outside of Flint but um but you
got nobody there no friends no family we
have family but it's not really like a
support system right like they're not
very good support system so so why do
you all live there
but we want to move out but right now we
just can't afford it we just don't have
the ability to do so okay
so man how on is gonna be with you it's
it's early in the morning and I don't
want to come after you early in the
morning but I think I I I'm a very
important person I take things very
bluntly so give it to me so
I want you to fully grasp what you've
experienced over the last six months or
a year
um probably the last two to five years
and probably even further back how old
are your kids one more one more question
how was your kids
seven and three seven three
okay
so man you have experienced one
trauma after another after another
Marine Corps is bonding it's connecting
and it's hard on your body in your mind
you agree I agree okay
um you see some stuff and you experience
some stuff agreed
I agree okay then you get out you lose
your community you lose your mission
your purpose your your your check in and
check out which some people love that
it's I I hear often when I work with
veterans It's really disorienting
because you just had somebody telling
you when and what for so long and in
such micro units of a day
um that it's disorienting is that your
experience
um not really because I was I mean I was
able to transition pretty quickly I mean
it wasn't really hard for me to
transition because I was still I was
still in school okay while I was in the
course so the transition was very simple
for me who who became your friends after
you got out your gang your buddies
essentially people within law school and
other Marines I don't hang out with law
students man you know that
um you know I was a dean of students at
a law school for a while
for years and that's a whole other
Adventure right so then you go to law
school and I studied law student mental
health that's another trauma a big one
and a slow drip one that slowly drowns
you agreed
I definitely agree okay then you're
you're with a you're married to somebody
who's experienced some significant
relational trauma and that's just heart
agreed yep then her body continues to go
to war with her until it finally can
push it all the way to get that snowball
all the way on top of the hill and
pushes it down and her body says we're
out agreed yep and by the way you got
two little ones one that's old enough to
get in everything and one that still
needs diapers
last two years right over the last two
years right then you are working a job
that you hate and you get fired like on
trying to help your family getting fired
from a job is a big trauma and then and
then you fail the bar and then and then
and then
and so I want you to just pause for a
second in the middle of this and I know
you felt it and it's all over the place
I want you to hear me tell you you've
been through hell
agreed
I agree have you taken a big deep breath
and dropped your shoulders and just said
crap
every day
okay
so here's what happens when people find
themselves in this situation
their brain begins over time loved ones
community that your path out which was
law school your plan which was law
school back to Jag and then law schools
do private practice and now I'm
underwriting loans and I don't even like
that the mortgage industry is ridiculous
it's a mess everything's a mess and then
this and then this and then oh my gosh I
get fired and it's not even fair and and
and
what your brain starts to do is look at
every potential out whether it's
relational whether it's occupational
whether it is
um connection with family whatever it is
as dead end dead end dead end dead end
and the word that you feel right now is
absolutely trapped Fair
yep you got nowhere to go
and so what I want to I want to
challenge you
is when you say I got nobody I'm gonna
call bullcrap on that
when you say we just we just don't can't
leave here we're just stuck here I'm
gonna call bullcrap on that
when you say I just I just gotta I just
have to
what I want to do is push on that
because you got two you're too smart you
got too many skills and you've been
through too much and you're too much of
an asset to the community that my kids
are growing up in
so I want you to hear me say it's just a
fellow dad forget all the TV and all the
radius like I need you in my community
you know too much you're too valuable to
me
to underwrite loans and some crappy job
that you don't even like
Fair
yeah okay
so what I need you to do is decide
I'm gonna find a job that's going to pay
us to move the last three jobs I've
taken they've paid me to move
you can have that too
they they help underwrite my transition
from wherever to wherever you don't need
to get to Texas where it's warmer come
here to Nashville where it's just
bonkers
you can move if your family is not safe
you got to decide I'm going to make it a
mission to get people in my life get
people in my life around me where I can
have Community because I can't do life
without it whether that's a local church
whether that's friends whether it's
getting together a Marine Group whatever
that is you've reached a point where you
have to have Recon and you've got to
make it an A1 priority
Fair
yeah when's the last time you went and
worked out took care of your body and
your mind did something for you
a couple months ago okay
so when we feel trapped we just get that
that that spiral gets Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter and then the only
thing that works man is a 12-pack and
Netflix or some game of some sort or
video whatever the thing is
I'm telling you this stuff and you know
it tell me where you're stuck my brother
I just I just don't know where to go I
mean that's I've reached out to churches
I've done therapy I've done
like everyone I would normally reach out
to was just dealing with so much [ __ ]
right now that like I it's that I'm not
adding on to it it's not something that
I do okay
um
yeah oh I just I just drop it in John
you're not a burden
you're not a burden man
and I get feeling like you're at the end
you're doing a lot of reaching out
but I'd love to see you here's what I
want you to do I want you to do this
want you to take out a piece of paper
and do this off air and then here's what
I'm going to do I'm going to have you
back on this show because I want to walk
through this with you over the next five
six months is that fair will you do that
with me yeah okay
I want you to sit down today alone by
yourself I want you to take an hour
I don't want you to write down all the
stressors in your life every single one
of them start to finish
from brokenhearted about my wife to
wife's illness to kids if your kids got
learning distance but whatever the thing
is money stress reached out to this
person denied counseling sucks I want
you to write down every stressor you
have
and I want you to get it at arm's length
out of your head and onto a piece of
paper so that it becomes a series of
challenges to work through not something
that is debilitating and taking over
your body
will you do that yeah okay I want you to
do that and then Kelly's going to reach
back out to you and we're going to do
this again in a few weeks
and in a few weeks you're gonna I want
you to read me the list all these
challenges and I want you to pick three
or four of the biggest ones and begin to
don't don't go call somebody you are
good
I want you to create a plan that's going
to start with I need to start exercising
and taking care of my body
I need to quit drinking I need to quit
and I'm just picking that up I'm not
making that up I don't even know if you
drink or not do you
no okay so I'm just picking some
whatever the thing is I'm gonna start by
honoring my body period number two I'm
gonna start by playing with my key just
doing something silly like playing with
my kids
number three I'm gonna start applying
for jobs in other states
what's the worst that can happen they
can tell us a no great I'm on to the
next
I'm going to sign up for the bar and I
am going to start making some hard phone
calls to people because I'm not a burden
and I'm going to need some babysitting
over the next six months because I got
to study and pass this test I need to
pass this test I'm not giving up on this
I want you to begin to come up with a
plan and then in a few weeks we're going
to circle back and I'm going to walk
alongside you is that fair and if you
start these things and I want you to
come at me hard it's bullcrap Dooney I
call this call this nothing nothing and
we're going to walk through every bit of
it and your journey is going to help
millions of people you in
yeah all right so today your your
homework assignment for today's write
all your stressors down get them all
lined up and begin with the top three to
five and want to make a plan and you're
gonna be uncomfortable and it's going to
be weird and you're gonna have to keep
thinking I'm not a burden I'm not a
burden and I start with me and then I'm
with my kids and then we're going from
there
okay
John I need you in my community and I
want you in my community you're just
feeling trapped and I need you to hear
me say you're not trapped and it starts
with taking little tiny steps Little
Steps
towards something new not accepting
I just can't I got no one I can't do a
thing I can't I don't accept that and I
don't want you to accept that either
because it's not true